C'est la fin de l'année, et je me suis dit
que ça pourrait être cool de revenir sur ce que j'ai fait cette année.
Déjà pour vous livrer mon ressenti, et aussi vous faire découvrir
à ceux qui n'ont pas tout suivi, c'est normal de pas tout suivre ne vous inquiétez pas.
Parce que pour moi 2014, ça a vraiment été une année formidable
En terme de rencontre, de projet, tout ça, bref, c'est parti !
Pendant les vacances de Noël, j'ai eu l'idée de faire une vidéo sur les réunions.
Champagne!
J'ai directement proposé ça à Ludovic et Julien et je regrette absolument pas
parce que ça a été le tournage le plus marrant de toute ma vie !
On a vraiment passé l'aprèm' à se taper fous rires sur fous rires !
Je suis allé 48 heures à Las Vegas, pas pour les biatches et le poker mais pour le CES,
le salon des nouvelles technologies, c'est vraiment un endroit de dingue !
Le Geek qui était en moi était totalement comblé
Le magazine Respect Mag, nous a demandé de faire la couverture avec euh...Norman
alors c'était vraiment super de rencontrer l'équipe, c'est un super magazine
gratuit en plus, la thématique du respect c'est super intéressant et euh... je porte un noeud papillon.
Voilà, j'ai... j'ai pas de... d'anecdotes en plus...
J'ai participé dans la même semaine à deux tournages, le thriller du Before
avec Jérome et Luigi clash Mario avec Hugo. C'était la semaine embrasse tes potes,
voilà ça... ça arrive hein? D'ailleurs les filles si vous aimez bien Jérôme, il embrasse très mal hein?
par contre Hugo euh...
J'ai fait une parodie de la photo la plus retweetée du monde, 3 millions de retweet,
c'est... c'est un score pas mal, c'est vrai. Et il s'avère que mon tweet a été le plus retweeté de France en 2014,
donc ça fait extrêmement plaisir, j'aimerais remercier bein... mon agent, mon producteur, bref toutes ces personnes
qui n'existent pas.
J'ai dépassé les 5 millions d'abonnés, ça... ça m'a énormément touché, c'est vraiment un truc de fou,
et pour vous remercier; j'ai répondu à vos questions.
Ta réaction quand t'as eu 5 millions d'abonnés?
Yes!
Wow wow wow t'es mignon tu fais moins de bruit! Okay?
Oui Patricia!
W9 à organisé une remise des prix des vidéos d'humour sur Internet, et je suis reparti avec deux prix,
voilà, ça me fait très plaisir, ils sont en plastique. Et c'était aussi l'occasion de m'habiller classe,
puisque j'ai porté un haut-de-forme de 55 centimètres fait sur mesure.
Pour pécho en boîte, c'est... c'est le mieux, moi je connais pas mieux. C'est parti.
Alors je sais, une émission de télé qui remet des prix pour Internet c'est un petit peu du foutage de gueule,
mais j'ai pu rencontrer Rémi Gaillard, voilà c'était super important pour moi, parce que c'est un petit peu mon idole !
Et j'ai fait un pogo avec lui et Anthony Kavanagh et je me suis foulé la cheville !
Du coup, deux semaines de béquilles... Super soirée, vraiment ! hein?
J'ai été l'invité du Grand Journal à côté d'une de mes idoles : Aaron Paul de la série Breaking Bad !
C'est ma série préférée, voilà, tout simplement !
Du coup j'étais vraiment comme un gamin. En plus il est super sympa, on a discuté genre...
Huit secondes ! C'était cool...
Stop it!
Ma boutique en ligne de t-shirts a fêté son premier anniversaire,
c'est...c'est super important pour moi parce que, bin... le dessin, ça... ça fait vraiment partie de ma vie !
Quand j'étais gamin je voulais devenir dessinateur !
Et j'adore faire mes visuels de A à Z et ensuite les porter.
Euh... Ah bin ho... hop! bein? quel hasard!
J'ai fais une vidéo pour la promo du film X-MEN avec Julien.
On est allés à Londres pour tourner avec Hugh Jackman.
C'était vraiment un truc de ouf
J'avoue que... quand on ma dit que on pouvait avoir Hugh Jackman dans notre vidéo...
euh... j'y ai pas cru, hein? Jusqu'à ce que je me retrouve devant lui j'pensais vraiment que il allait annuler, ou décaler, ou alors faire totalement autre-chose...
mais ne pas être là et finalement il était là et il avait, une bonne humeur et une énergie vraiment incroyable c'était vraiment, mortel ce tournage.
Pour moi c'est vraiment dingue en tant que... que youtubeur voilà de me retrouver avec des gens d'Hollywood.
C'est un truc de ouf!
Avec Julien et Ludovic on n'a pas pu s'empêcher de faire les réunions 2 et on s'était dit: Viens pour la blague! on demande à Dany Boon de faire une apparition genre il va venir...
Et il est venu, voilà c'était vraiment marrant de tourner avec lui et après on s'est dit: Viens euh...
on demande à Jessica Alba de faire une apparition et euh... on a... on attend.
On est en attente... Jess si tu nous entends?
Direction Los Angeles pour l'E3, le plus grand salon des jeux vidéos sur la planète terre.
C'est vraiment le paradis des gameurs, c'est la deuxième année que je vais là-bas, c'est vraiment super j'ai pu faire plein de vidéos pour ma chaîne Cyprien Gaming...
c'était vraiment fun et j'ai pu croiser Omar Sy qui est l'homme le plus sympa du monde.
Omar: Et mais c'est... Cyprien: Et mais c'est Omar Sy
Cyprien: de X-MEN. Omar: qu'est ce que tu fais?
On m'a invité à l'émission Fort Boyard c'est vraiment un rêve de gosse.
J'adorais cette émission quand j'était gamin et j'ai pu y aller avec mes potes Maxime et Jérome.
On s'est éclaté, j'ai adoré me prendre des lombrics sur le visage.
Vraiment un super moment, j'y retourne quand ils veulent et si ils veulent pas j'y retourne quand-même je prend un bateau je m'en bat les steaks je grimpe comme ça.
Avec Squeezie on a animé le Cyprien Gaming Show, un spectacle au Grand Rex avec 2500 personnes retransmis sur YouTube.
C'était vraiment... C'était vraiment super enrichissant c'était vraiment une super expérience.
Parce-que tenir 2 heures sur scène, ça n'a rien à voir avec 10 minutes en vidéo.
Du coup on a appris vraiment plein de trucs
Mon moment préféré c'est bien sur la petite surprise quand toute la salle a trouvé un pistolet Nerf caché sous son siège et a visé Squeezie.
Alors 2500 fléchettes dans la gueule, ça fait pas du bien!
D'ailleurs j'ai vraiment vécu plein de trucs de ouf avec la chaîne Cyprien Gaming cette année.
La violoniste Lindsey Stirling qui est passée nous voir.
Je me suis planté en jet-ski.
J'ai fais une parodie des Sims.
Un top 10 en rap.
Un live avec des joueurs du PSG dont David Luiz.
Bref, avec cette chaîne on fait vraiment tout le temps n'importe quoi et... et ça ça me fait extrêmement plaisir.
Grosse fierté pour moi d'avoir été choisi pour être dans la campagne d'affichage de YouTube dans les rues de Paris.
ça fait vraiment bizarre d'avoir sa tête en énorme sur une affiche.
Et j'ai pu rencontrer Robert Kincl, le patron de YouTube on est directement devenu potes.
Il y a une sorte de... de complicité qui s'est crée c'est devenu le parrain de mon fils euh... bref euh... non ça c'est pas vrai.
6 millions d'abonnés voilà je sais même pas quoi dire pour vous remercier.
Alors ce que j'ai fait c'est que je vous ai livré quelques anecdotes sur moi que vous ne connaissez pas.
J'adore quand on me masse le crâne mais vraiment dès... dès qu'on me touche la tête, même le visage ça m’endors immédia...
ZZZ...
La chaîne de télé Gulli a récompensé les artistes préférés des jeunes et j'ai gagné le prix du webcomique préféré.
Voilà c'est un prix... en mousse.
Pas mal ça!
Le magazine Science et Vie Junior, mon magazine préféré quand j'étais gamin m'a demandé de faire une couv.
J'ai accepté dans la seconde alors ça se voit pas mais j'étais super content.
Oui je... je suis content comme ça.
Après les affiches dans Paris, YouTube m'a invité dans le YouTube Rewind.
C'est... C'est le mix des vidéos buzz de l'année en musique.
J'ai adoré le tournage, c'était à Londres et j'ai rencontré plein de youtubeurs géniaux qui venait de... d'Angleterre, d'Allemagne.
Et ça vous parle peut-être pas beaucoup mais pour moi ça... ça me touche énormément parce-que c'est un petit peu... un accomplissement en tant que Youtuber voilà.
Yes!
Troisième voyage au Etats-Unis cette année cette fois ci c'était pour faire une surprise à MisterV.
Lui faire rencontrer son idole... Tony Parker.
J'ai vraiment adoré ce voyage parce-que ça a mis plein d'étoiles dans les yeux de MisterV.
Et ça fait toujours euh... plaisir de faire plaisir à un pote tout simplement.
Et l'année se termine sur un projet que je vous dévoile maintenant je suis en train de tourner un court-métrage que j'ai écrit.
Alors c'est tout nouveau pour moi c'est une vidéo beaucoup plus longue que d'habitude.
Euh... j'incarne un nouveau personnage ça n'a rien à voir avec mes autres vidéos et j'aime bien changer.
J'aime bien tester des nouveaux trucs c'est ça que j'aime bien avec internet c'est que finalement on peut faire ce qu'on veut.
Et pas faire tout-le-temps la même chose j'espère que vous apprécierez ça sort en janvier.
Et pour finir je voulais tout simplement vous remercier parce que...  ben tout ce que je vis c'est... c'est grâce à vous si... si je peux vivre euh... mes rêves.
Voilà les rêves de gamin c'est... c'est grâce à vos... à vos clics comme ça et de me suivre sur mes vidéos.
ça me fait énormément plaisir donc encore merci... j'espère que vous avez passé une bonne année 2014.
Et j'espère que 2015 sera encore meilleure.
à très vite!
Sous-titres: Ronexx
Mais... je sais pas parce que en fait moi je... je voudrais m'abonner à la chaîne, comment on fait?
Eh ben c'est parfaitement gratuit, tu clique avec ton doigt.
D'accord! ben je vais le faire.
Cyprien: Voilà! Omar: Faites le aussi! hein? c'est une très bonne idée.
Et je suis content de te rencontrer.
Moi aussi!
Oh calin! calin!
cyprien: Ha! Omar: Aller! à bientôt!
C'est du lourd quand-même.